[Musica]
oggi noi stiamo vivendo il futuro che
immaginavamo trent'anni fa trent'anni
sono il periodo anno più anno meno dal
momento in cui io mi sono laureato
presso l'università della calabria a
oggi l'università è cambiata è diventato
un patrimonio di enorme di
intellettualità è diventato un punto di
riferimento mondiale per una serie di
discipline scientifiche non solo ed è un
discorso che io mi trovo molto spesso a
fare con i colleghi più giovani
raccontanto appunto di come 28 anni fa
quando ho iniziato a lavorare per una
azienda informatica è una multinazionale
francese all'avanguardia nella
tecnologia all'epoca che e ho cominciato
un percorso che è dettato dall
evoluzione tecnologica meraviglioso
straordinario che non potevamo neanche
immaginare all'epoca e volendo fare
ancora un passo indietro nel 1975 bill
gates il fondatore della microsoft
prevedeva che da lì a breve ci sarebbe
stato un computer su ogni scrivania e su
ogni in ogni casa beh insomma bill gates
ha sbagliato perché in realtà siamo
andati molto oltre oggi noi abbiamo in
tasca ognuno uno smartphone che non è
paragonabile nemmeno all'idea che aveva
all'epoca bill gates sulla potenza e
sulla possibilità che si possono avere
con con questi strumenti che oggi
abbiamo in tasca
quindi questo periodo questa evoluzione
tecnologica e stata un'avventura
meravigliosa un'era geologica è
trascorsa negli ultimi 30 anni e noi ci
siamo
alimentati di questi sogni anche
attraverso la letteratura attraverso i
film e mi viene sempre spesso da citare
un film che amo molto che 2001 odissea
nello spazio di stanley kubrick è un
film del 1968 quindi di più di 50 anni
fa
stanley kubrick immaginava che il
computer di bordo di questa navicella
spaziale che sta viaggiando in
nello spazio più profondo avesse un
intelligenza artificiale enorme sapeva
leggere il labiale batteva gli umani a
scacchi è un certo punto prende la
decisione di sopprimere anche
l'equipaggio e ci riesce parzialmente e
della cosa più spaventosa probabilmente
e che prova dei sentimenti umani ha
paura nel momento in cui viene
disattivato ora sta alle pubbliche
probabilmente è stato fin troppo
visionario oggi sappiamo che siamo
ancora molto lontani dal poter far
provare dei sentimenti umani ai computer
ma l'intelligenza artificiale si sta
muovendo a passi da gigante
gli scacchi ormai sono diventati sono
stati superati da la problematica di
essere vincenti nei confronti dell'uomo
però perché cito stalle pubbliche e 2001
nello spazio perché questo film
introduce è già nel 1968 un tema
importantissimo che sono gli effetti
collaterali che derivano da questa
evoluzione tecnologica la possibilità
che noi abbiamo oggi sono infinitamente
più ampie rispetto a 50 anni fa e questo
porta a una rivoluzione che non è
soltanto tecnologica ma è una
rivoluzione sociale una rivoluzione
culturale di rapporti tra le persone tra
gli uomini e questo significa che come
appunto ci dice un sociologo del secolo
scorso di un del anders che per millenni
l'uomo ha sognato di realizzare delle
cose adesso stiamo realizzando più di
quello che in realtà riusciamo a
governare è questo allora è il punto
focale dobbiamo concentrarci
sull'evoluzione tecnologica come un
compagno di viaggio saperla governare
si parla tantissimo di intelligenza
artificiale dei nostri dati personali
delle complicazioni delle implicazioni
etiche legate magari alle bioingegneri e
così via
allora allora il punto al quale voglio
arrivare è che in qualche modo già
questi temi sono stati affrontati e si
sono indirizzati attraverso i principi
dello sviluppo sostenibile secondo le
direttrici economico sociali e
ambientali e l'unesco nel 2015 ha
fissato ben 17 obiettivi da realizzare
entro il 2030 che sono degli obiettivi
bellissimi sfilanti e tutte le nazioni
che fanno parte dell'organismo delle
nazioni unite devono impostare le loro
politiche di sviluppo seguendo questi
principi si va dall annullamento della
povertà allora vendola fa mai fatto di
garantire sanità salute quindi e
istruzione a tutti di seguire uno
sviluppo che sia ecocompatibile la
tecnologia l'evoluzione tecnologica è
uno strumento che deve poter aiutare
nella realizzazione di questi di questi
obiettivi
allora mi sono chiesto ma
io sono un tecnofilo lavoro con la
tecnologia guardo alla tecnologia con
curiosità la tecnologia può aiutare
anche lo sviluppo
nella nostra terra nella calabria nel
meridione a cosenza e mi è venuto in
mente di quanto qualche decennio fa agli
inizi degli anni 80 era un ragazzo
sentivo in televisione dibattiti e si
ripeteva sempre la stessa cosa il
meridione deve superare un ritardo
rispetto al settentrione di sviluppo
economico sociale di qualche decennio
rispetto al settentrione
ebbene passato sono passati 40 anni e
questo divario non solo non si è colmato
ma si è addirittura allargato allora
forse pensare soltanto allo sviluppo
tecnologico come l'elemento che ci
permetta di fare anche nel meridione uno
di attuare uno sviluppo sostenibile uno
sviluppo compatibile anche con il resto
dell'italia il resto dell'europa
non basta bisogna cercare quindi di
mettere a fuoco un paradigma diverso per
indirizzare uno sviluppo anche nella
nella nostra terra dare un senso a
questa evoluzione tecnologica così forte
e su questo forse ci viene in aiuto un
filosofo tedesco che già nel 1953 martin
heidegger in un suo famoso discorso
sulla tecnica ci da due definizioni
della tecnica della tecnologia
la prima è di tipo strumentale ci dice
la tecnica è un mezzo in vista dei fini
la seconda invece è di tipo
antropologica ci dice che la la tecnica
è un attività dell'uomo
allora se dalla prima ricaviamo speranza
abbiamo speranza che la tecnica la
tecnologia ci aiuterà a migliorare la
nostra vita a trovare delle delle cure
per malattie che oggi sono sono
incurabili dalla seconda ricaviamo
probabilmente un sentimento ancora più
importante che la fiducia perché noi
mettiamo mettiamo al centro della dello
sviluppo della tecnica
l'uomo e dell'uomo dobbiamo avere
fiducia quindi forse questo può essere
il paradigma per inquadrare
uno sviluppo tecnologico che sia
compatibile con uno sviluppo sostenibile
e quindi dobbiamo cominciare forse a
immaginare la tecnologia al servizio
della persona in maniera tale che la
persona servendosi delle persone
servendosi della tecnologia possono
acquisire fiducia una fiducia personale
che si alimenta e che crea un circolo
virtuoso fino ad arrivare a quella
fiducia al sociale di cui parlavo questa
fotografia non l'ho scelto a caso è una
mia fotografia privata perché il ragazzo
raffigurato e mio figlio un adolescente
e la fotografia scattata mia figlia
siamo appassionati di fotografia ma non
c'entra nulla però è proprio per
sottolineare questo questo passaggio è
il fatto di aver cura dei giovani di
pensare che i giovani possono essere al
centro ha utilizzati utilizzando
opportunamente l'evoluzione tecnologica
ci permette forse di guardare al futuro
in una maniera un pochettino più più più
facile da immaginare e soprattutto più
sostenibile a questo punto io vi vorrei
parlare di una di una società che
conosco molto bene che questo circolo
virtuoso tra tecnologia e fiducia
sociale lo ha realizzato proprio qui a
cosenza e ntt data è una società una
multinazionale giapponese ntt sta per
nippon telegraph in telefoniche e che a
circa 120 mila dipendenti in tutto il
mondo diviso in tutti i continenti nelle
maggiori nazioni del mondo in italia ha
una sede con circa 3.500 dipendenti in
otto diverse città italiane
una di queste cosenza cosenza per
numerosità e la terza in italia abbiamo
300 dipendenti qui a cosenza dopo milano
e roma ma soprattutto è la sede con
l'età media più bassa 33 anni ai maison
incluso anche io in questa media
analizzandola drasticamente però tante e
ltt ha posto al centro diciamo del suo
processo di sviluppo le persone perché
le persone sono il vero capitale
aziendale e si è data dai principi di
sviluppo che sono coerenti con i
principi dello sviluppo sostenibile di
cui parlavamo
ma che ci ha fornito l'unesco quindi si
parla di ethical business si parla di
sostenibilità del suo ambiente si parla
di responsabilità sociale
allora che cosa è successo ntt data qui
a cosenza ha saputo guadagnarsi un posto
importante nell'ambito del panorama
mondiale proprio del gruppo e net.it
grazie allo sviluppo delle persone e
della cura delle persone che sono
diventati il centro dello sviluppo di
questa azienda quindi non soltanto una
preoccupazione dell'azienda di
sviluppare le competenze professionali
delle persone ma soprattutto di
sviluppare le competenze personali
attraverso applicando delle delle delle
politiche di restituzione abbiamo fatto
in modo che diversi giovani che non
avevano trovato delle opportunità di
lavoro favorevoli qui da noi sono
rientrate per cominciare a lavorare una
nuova avventura nella nostra azienda
abbiamo iniziato un programma di
avvicinamento nel 2016 alla tecnologia e
al digitale delle donne abbiamo ancora
troppe poche donne in italia che seguono
le lauree stand quindi le lauree
dell'area le lauree scientifiche abbiamo
aumentato progressivamente il numero di
donne che sono impiegate in azienda
ricavandone un beneficio enorme perché
portano un bagaglio di conoscenza un
bagaglio di professionalità enorme
abbiamo iniziato una serie di attività
che hanno un impatto sul territorio da
due anni seguiamo un programma di
chiamiamo codici nelle scuole andiamo
nelle scuole elementari e facciamo dei
corsi di programmazione dei bambini di 6
7 anni e abbiamo raggiunto in due anni
11.000 bambini e bambine 500 nella
provincia di cosenza
e in questi giorni poi un evento
bellissimo lunedì
e cominciato la settimana
dell'innovazione un evento unico al
mondo nel borgo antico di castrolibero
in questo momento stasera ci sarà la
serata conclusiva si stanno confrontando
più di cento persone provenienti da
tutto il mondo colleghi soprattutto
clienti che provengono dal giappone
dalla germania dagli stati uniti start
up docenti universitari che stanno
vivendo nel borgo di castrolibero ri
facendo rivivere un po quella che era
qualche centinaio di anni fa un borgo
soltanto che invece di utilizzare le
botteghe per i mestieri quali falegnami
fabbri oggi ci sano sono lì dei gruppi
di technology che si stanno confrontando
e arriveranno a determinare delle linee
di intervento per il futuro tutto questo
quindi ha permesso di creare nelle t t
da da qui a cosenza una fiducia sociale
che unita all'innovazione tecnologica ci
è permesso di far lavorare giovani
brillanti laureati calabresi ma anche di
altre regioni del meridione su tematiche
al top della tecnologia come l'internet
delle cose
l'intelligenza artificiale il la
robotica alla realtà aumentata
alcune applicazioni sviluppate qui a
cosenza alcune che stanno ancora
sviluppando verranno utilizzate durante
la loro in piedi di tokyo 20 20 l'anno
prossimo che si annunciano come le
olimpiadi più tecnologiche di sempre
quindi cosenza è diventato un polo di
conoscenza tecnologica e di fiducia
sociale come dicevamo prima e questo per
perché perché è stato possibile proprio
coniugando questi due fattori a creare
lavoro e la conseguenza di questa
creazione di lavoro è stata la creazione
di 300 posti di lavoro e non è un gioco
di parole perché bisogna distinguere tra
il lavoro e il posto di lavoro per
troppo tempo le azioni politiche sociali
si sono orientate alla crisi sono mirate
alla creazione di posti di lavoro ma
basta girare nelle periferie delle
grandi città e non solo delle grandi
città meridionali per scoprire i
capannoni abbandonati dove si immaginava
di creare posti di lavoro senza avere
una radice forte che fosse il lavoro
oro significativo che può dare dignità
all'uomo ora
e avevo iniziato questa questo racconto
dicendovi che la meridionalità
sostenibile in questo caso sì ci
limitiamo a cosenza la calabresità
sostenibile è un fattore moltiplicativo
di opportunità a cosenza questo fattore
moltiplicativo vale 100 perché nel 2001
quando abbiamo iniziato qui a cosenza
eravamo in tre oggi siamo 300 e speriamo
che questo fattore moltiplicativo
continui a a crescere
e chiaro che in diciotto anni si
succedono tante cose e stata
un'esperienza e un esaltante bellissima
non priva di momenti di difficoltà nel
2011 quando la sede di cosenza occupava
80 persone ntt data ha deciso di
acquistare la società nella quale ci
trovavamo all'epoca ebbe un brivido
lungo la schiena ci è venuto perché
immaginare che una società giapponese
con più di 100.000 dipendenti nel mondo
con le sedi nelle più grandi città del
mondo tokyo new york londra monaco di
baviera parigi potesse a dare un impulso
o ancora occuparsi di una strategia per
una piccola sede nel sud d'italia in
calabria la regione forse più disastrata
dell'intero continente europeo
qualche dubbio ci è venuto è però la
risposta sta in questa slide
noi abbiamo proseguito anzi abbiamo
aumentato il ritmo di crescita per
arrivare a 300 persone dopo 5 dopo otto
anni dal 2011
non solo ma oggi cosenza viene citata
nei laboratori innovativi del gruppo al
pari di palo alto e di tokyo
avevo anche detto che la meridionalità
sostenibile è un fattore di un modello
di riferimento ed è quello che è
successo perché quattro anni fa seguendo
il proprio i driver principali del
successo della sede di cosenza che sono
stati l'assunzione di giovani e
l'innovazione tecnologica e l'incremento
di numero di donne tra le persone che
lavorano con noi abbiamo esportato
questo modello a napoli dove nel 2015
lavoravano 40 persone ed era una sede
poi mi hanno confessato i colleghi da
dove si aspettava che da un momento
all'altro
l'azionista decidesse di chiudere ebbene
applicando questi tre fattori che vi ho
raccontato siamo passati da 40 a 250
risorse
fin qui la storia la mia esperienza ma
veramente la cosenza a cosenza la
calabria meridione possono essere un
acceleratore verso il futuro
allora chiaramente una domanda oziosa la
risposta è sì potrei dare una decina di
spiegazioni vennero soltanto tre la
prima è questa esistono nel meridione
d'italia delle università eccellenti che
ci forniscono risorse ragazzi e ragazzi
con delle competenze eccezionali
sì perché in un mondo dominato dalla
tecnologia è possibile portare il lavoro
laddove ci sono le competenze per
poterlo svolgere e la terza e lo dico
con un orgoglio essendo anch'io di
cosenza naturalmente perché i
meridionali che non si rassegnano al
proprio destino che non accettano
passivamente il loro destino esprimono
una potenziale inimmaginabile
l'altra domanda che mi sento porre ma in
un mondo globalizzato come puoi pensare
che la calabria questo posto sperduto il
sud italia cosenza il meridione possano
competere in uno scenario internazionale
allora anche qui la risposta per me è
semplice se le condizioni per poter
lavorare per dare un lavoro dignitoso le
persone sono rispettate allora i
meridionali sanno esprimere delle
capacità uniche siamo orgogliosi siamo
testardi sappiamo lavorare in team
sappiamo fare squadra e soprattutto al
contrario di quello che vogliono farci
credere
da qualche tempo a questa parte siamo
accoglienti riusciamo a valorizzare le
differenze culturali ad accogliere e
integrare queste differenze culturali
facendo moltiplicare il nostro valore
questa è la terra di mimmo lucano e
allora e allora la risposta è sì
possiamo competere in uno scenario
internazionale
se coniughiamo la fiducia sociale di cui
vi ho parlato con l'evoluzione
tecnologica riusciamo a raggiungere la
meridionalità sostenibile è la mia
speranza e perciò guardo al futuro lo
vedo meno sfocato e che
cliccando questi principi qualsiasi
altra azienda qualsiasi altro
imprenditori in qualsiasi campo
tecnologico si vogliano applicare
replicando questo tipo di modello
possiamo compiere una rivoluzione
straordinaria mano attenzione non è una
una rivoluzione per il meridione per la
calabria per cosenza
sarebbe una rivoluzione per l'italia
grazie
[Applauso]